let's continue with our proof of stoke's
theorem and this time we're going to
focus on the other side of stoke's
theorem we're going to try to figure out
what is the line integral over the
boundary c where this is c right over
here the boundary of our surface of f
dot dr what we're going to see is that
we're going to get the exact same result
as we have right up here but before we
do that i'm going to take a little bit
of a of a detour to kind of build up to
this so let's just let's just take this
and put it to the side for now actually
let me actually just delete it right now
and what i'm actually going to do is i'm
going to focus on this region down here
this region in the x y plane and in
particular so this this is path this is
path c which is the boundary of our
surface i'm going to focus on the path
that is the boundary of this region this
path that sits in the x y plane and i
will call that path i will call that
path c1 and so we want we can think
about a parameterization of just that
path in the x y plane we could say that
c 1
c 1 could be parameterized as
x
is equal to x of t
and y is equal to is also a function of
t and t is obviously our parameter and
it can go between a
and
b so maybe when t is equal to a it sits
right here and then as t gets larger and
larger and larger it goes all the way
around and eventually when t is equal to
b it gets to that exact same point so
that's our parameterization right there
and now just to make the rest of this
proof a little bit more understandable
i'm going to give you a little bit of a
review of something imagine that we have
some vector field g
and g at minimum is defined on the x y
plane so and it could be defined other
places but let's say that g is equal to
m
of x y
i
plus n
of x y
n of x y j
now what would the line integral and
this is all review we've seen this long
time ago what would be the line integral
over the path c1 not c but this path
that sits in the xy plane what would be
the line integral over the path c1 and
i'll even
i like to write that sometimes of and
i'm using g so i don't get confused with
f our original vector field of g
of g our vector field here along that
path g dot dr
g
dot
dr
well dr
dr is just going to be equal to dx
dxi
dxi
plus d y
d y j so if you take the dot product of
these two things right over here you're
going to get you're going to get the
line integral over our path c1 remember
c1 is this path down here let me do in
that same color so you don't think i'm
changing colors on you
the line integral over our path c1 but
when you take this dot product you have
the you multiply the x components and
then add that to the product of the y
component so you have m times dx
you have m
times dx
m times dx
plus
plus
n times dy
n times dy i just took the dot product
of g and dr n times d y and when you
evaluate these things one way to think
about it is that dx is the same thing
dx is the same thing as let me write it
up here in a different color
and dx is the same thing as dx the
derivative of x with respect to t dt and
same logic for y d y is equal to the
derivative of y with respect to t
dt one way to think about it these dts
cancel out and you're just left with dx
and this is an important thing to think
about because then this allows us to
take this line integral into the domain
of our parameter so then this will be
equal to
this will be equal to
this will be equal to the integral in
the domain of our parameter so now we
are in the t domain and t is going to
vary between a and b
we are in the t domain between a and b
this is going to be equal to m
m
times instead of writing dx i'm going to
write dx dt dt
so it's going to be dx
let me write it this way
dx
the derivative of x with respect to t
dt
that's the first expression
plus
plus n
and then the exact same thing times d y
dt
n times d y
dt n times d y dt
dt
dt these are all equivalent statements
now with all of that out of the way and
this is really all of this is really
just a reminder so that the rest of this
proof becomes a little bit intuitive
with that out of the way let's come up
with a parameterization for this path up
here for c
for c
remember we just did c1 down in the xy
plane now we're going to do c that sits
up here that kind of rises above the x y
plane well for c
x can still be the the parametrizations
for x and y can still be the exact same
thing because the x and y values are
going to be the exact same thing the x
value the x and y value here is the
exact same thing as the x and y value
there the only difference is we now have
a z component and we know we defined it
way up here our z component is going to
be a function is going to be a function
of x and y it tells us how high to go so
we can parameterize we can parameterize
c
as
we can parameterize c as
maybe i'll write it as a vector
so let me write it let me parameterize
so i'll write c as a vector
c
actually no i'll write it let me write
it this way let me write c
c can be written at let me do that
purple color
see
we can say is
x is x of t and actually let me write
this as a vector so i will write it and
i'll use a vector r not to be confused
with this r right over here so this is
these are two different r's but i'll
just use r's because that tends to be
the convention so in order to parameter
ic i'm going to it's going to be the
position vector r which is going to be a
function of t
and x is still just going to be x of t
x of t
i
plus y
of t
j and now we're going to have a z
component and z is going to be a
function of x and y which are in turn
functions of t so z is a function of x
which is a function of t and a function
of y which is a function of t
k that tells us how high above to
essentially get each of those points and
then once again we know that t is
between a and b t is greater than or
equal to a and less than or equal to b
so we have that parameterization right
there and now we can start to think
about we can start to think about the
line integral of f dot dr along this
path before we did dr along this path
now we're going to do dr on this path
right over here so we're now this this
is now our parameterization r
so i'll leave you there and i'll i'll
see you in the next video